a number of other useful helper methods
are available there too and it's a good
idea to look up the documentation about
each of them one of the most useful
properties is doc constructor which
makes it easy to tell what function was
used to create a certain object like all
properties doc constructor actually
points to a different object that's
stored elsewhere people frequently
confuse the object prototype with this
constructor function used to make all
objects so let's visualize the two in
different boxes for a moment as a
reminder of the way it's really laid out
inside your computer whenever you ask an
object about its dot constructor
property the object most likely doesn't
have a local dot constructor property so
the prototype chain gets consulted the
doc instructor property on the object
prototype points to the constructor
function for making objects and so that
object is provided as the result